[Musique]
les curieux et les passionnés ont été
ravis le dimanche 15 octobre c'était le
retour de la fête médiévale à
Châteaufort le centre-ville s'est vêtu
de ses plus beaux blasons et banderoles
pour la 37e édition de la Saint-Simon
près de 10000 personnes se sont
retrouvées pour vivre à la manière des
habitants du Moyen-Âge dans une ambiance
conviviale et familiale
comme chaque année de nombreux artisans
proposaient animation et stand pour
découvrir les coutumes aimé d'autrefis
c'est la c'est la grande fête du village
la foire Saint-Simon tous les 3è
dimanches d'octobre bien sûr tout le
village ce costumes il y a les stands de
galettes les jeux pour les enfants les
spectacles enfin oui c'est c'est un
incontournable du village oui prendre
des galettes des crêpes des
endouillettes des châignes la taverne
médiévale qui est là et qui est qui est
super avec des bons repas le jus de
pomme au pressoir et la soupe médiévale
à ne pas manquer dans son immense
choudron sur la place le public a
assister à un spectacle inédit au vol
libre d'aigles de faucon de buses et
d'autres
rapasses ils se sont détendus avec les
animaux de la ferme le public pouvait
aussi découvrir des activités
traditionnelles comme le pressage de
pommes manuel ou l'entraînement au
combat de chevalier c'est une fête de
village qu'on a mis en place il y a euh
une quarantaine d'années par des
amoureux de de l'histoire du médiéval
qui qui ont voulu faire une fête et et
qui ont créé cette fois un voyage dans
le temps pour lequel certains visiteurs
jouent le jeu je suis venu l'année
dernière pour la première fois j'ai bien
aimer parce que c'est très familial
c'est très sympathique Châteaufort vous
accueillera l'année prochaine pour sa
38e édition avec au programme les mêmes
ingrédients qui ont fait recette cette
année